when Albert Einstein set the speed limit
of the universe at the dawn of a new
century he proved that the space around
us and the time that we perceive are two
sides of the same thing it's called
space time and all the stuff in the
universe such as planets stars and US
sit inside it but that led Einstein to
another big Discovery space-time itself
can vibrate and Warp
the movement of very heavy objects like
two massive black holes crashing into
one another Ripple space-time like a rug
sending so-called gravitational waves in
every direction
they cross the universe carrying
information about the events that caused
them
they were detected here for the first
time seven years ago as they squeezed
and warped the Earth itself using this
machine called ligo
but astrophysicists thought there must
be more not just single waves caught by
chance but a background hum from the
millions of invisible collisions
throughout the history of our universe
so they looked to the universe for Clues
pulsars are dense dying stars that shoot
beams of light from both poles
astronomers know of over 2000 in our own
Galaxy and they say there should be a
billion others these are stars that have
run out of fuel and shrunk to just a few
kilometers in size but like a figure
skater as they pull their arms inward
they spin at hundreds of times per
second to astronomers on Earth they
blink like a steady clock
astrophysicists watched 67 of them for
15 years only then were they able to
detect that space time itself was
warping the blinks were slowing and
speeding up again the reason long slow
gravitational waves the kinds that can't
be detected from any single Observatory
on Earth coming from everywhere
all at once
it's a study that could only be
accomplished globally this discovery
come only from one group it's a several
different groups so it's a multinational
project U.S China Australia my
colleagues here in Australia in Europe
as well so that is some that's the power
and that's the beauty of the science the
science doesn't see a borders and to me
that is one of the most powerful
messages the first observation of
gravitational waves was a signal from
deep space now astrophysicists are
looking out through the lens of those
very waves to better understand the
structure of our universe Colin Baker Al
Jazeera